there is actually one golden rule that
silly as it may sound applies to all
esports and is actually really good
advice
don't
die
from the filthy casual to the seasoned
professional everybody knows the
importance of staying alive
[Music]
but what if there was an exception to
the rule what if there was a way to feed
over and over again
and still come out on top well that's a
concept upon which simon the baus ffs
hofferberg has built his entire league
of legends streaming career did it fall
for it
ah cringe man that's just cringe
wait you won a game with zero nine
question mark it's kind of what i do
it's kind of what i do i ink my ass off
and then i still win you see for the
bows
not all deaths are bad in fact for him
a good death
is his most powerful weapon
four levels up on wow
wait wow did you tp here to die
oh tactical
you don't know who the boss is buddy
usually what he does is he tries to
become the biggest pest
in the game he potentially is the
biggest pest in league of legends
because all he does is go for your
goddamn towers and your objectives oh
man
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
but perhaps the craziest thing is that
in spite of his countless deaths the
baus plays at the highest level of solo
queue in league of legends
no
damn let's go
i did it
you're damn right you're damn right i do
it i do it is easy for me baby so the
question naturally is how can someone
who dies so much
be so good why does his approach to the
game make him a contentious figure in
league's community and more importantly
how is he shaping the very language of
league of legends
solo
all right guys so before we dive into
the baus i just wanted to let you all
know that we have partnered with our
friends over at predator gaming to bring
you a holiday gift guide and to run you
through his own wish list i'm gonna send
you over to the score esports's resident
dank meme lord josh bury
[Music]
like dimitri just said we've teamed up
with our friends at predator gaming to
bring you a holiday gift guide that'll
give you some insight into what i'm
hoping to pick up this holiday season
and who knows maybe it'll inspire your
wish list as well so let's get into it
listen it's important to be comfortable
at your desk and recently a few of you
noticed that my chairs seem to be a bit
tilted
rest in peace marcus chairs seem to be
one of those things where it's just
worth it to spend a little bit of extra
money to get something that lasts one
option i've been thinking about is the
secret lab titan evo 2022 it seems
unlikely that santa would be able to
bring me a whole new back for christmas
so a quality chair has to be the next
best thing right while it's important to
always be comfortable when you're at
your desk there are only so many hours i
can spend there before i need a change
of scenery but i don't want to sacrifice
performance when i'm on the go
thankfully our friends at predator
gaming have my back sporting an intel
11th gen h-series core i7 processor and
an nvidia geforce rtx 3050 ti gpu the
predator triton 300se lets me play final
fantasy 14 wherever i happen to be at
that moment you can find one of these
bad boys at your local best buy now
let's get back to the episode
[Music]
okay so who exactly is this so-called
scion feeder making waves in league of
legends
well the baus hails from kunsangyen a
small suburb of the swedish capital
stockholm as a kid he first played
console games and spent hours watching
his brother surprise surprise play world
of warcraft but when he got his first
computer at the age of six he started
upon his own adventure but it was when
young simon made the move to league of
legends that he began to form his now
iconic identity yeah i wanted to be
recognized so i was like the mouse that
that people recognize that then i spell
it a bit weird with the a and the u and
then of course during that time it was
very common put like lol and like this
kind of stuff so i put ffs because that
was the one i thought was the best
and then it just it has been with me
ever since then i guess all throughout
high school the bows continued to play
league and after he graduated he was
determined to stream the game
professionally which he pitched to his
parents they were trying to get me to
college or get me get me
to work somewhere
and i i was gonna do that i'm not
i'm not
against it but i i came with a
proposition that i sat down with my
parents and i said i am good at this
game i want one year and if i don't make
it i'll go to college and i'll do
something with my life but i just need
one year so with the blessing of his
parents and the help of his brother the
baus officially launched his twitch
channel in august of 2018. now the baus
had been playing league since the middle
of season two and originally gravitated
towards champions like blitzcrank and
thresh but his streaming career really
began to take off because of how he
played one champion in particular
scion a character who loves nothing more
than smashing into enemies with his
unstoppable alt knocking them up for
days and literally screaming minions
into their faces making sion even more
intimidating to play against is his
passive which reanimates him upon death
and exponentially increases his auto
damage
how did he get here
[Music]
welcome to eu welcome to eu
the bows saw something in scion that no
one else did because while most people
deploy him as a front-line tank the baus
builds full balls to the wall attack
damage so that he can demolish you or
your turret with his passive or charge
into your base and destroy your nexus he
uses items like prowler's claw to dash
behind you when he dies and then drags
you down with him he builds hull breaker
and takes demolish which help him
absolutely melt structures put all of
this together and you've got possibly
the cheesiest and most infuriating
playstyle to go up against it's so
annoying when he has 20 deaths and he's
just obliterating your nexus and it's
like you can't i mean you can kill him
for the 20th time but it's like man you
kill him he gets his passive and then
he's blows up your goddamn nexus four
levels up on wow
wait wow did you tp here to die
oh tactical
you don't know who the boss is buddy
now he's gonna hit the tower watch
oh no he's gonna go for more
oh the prowlers call tech no way to get
a triple no
no
oh my if a normal top laner is 0 10
they're standing at their tier 3 and
they can't move okay they can't move if
bowse is 0-10
[Music]
it's proxying your whole family
and he's taking your towers
while he's zero 10. that's the
difference between the bows
and normal top laner zero zero ten
they're hugging their tier threes
praying for late game the boss is
zero twenty taking your whole nexus now
despite the fact that his strategy is
predicated on dying a lot the baus
somehow wins more often than he loses to
the point where he's finished in
challenger rank the past four seasons so
how is this possible how can someone die
so often and yet consistently beat some
of the best players on the planet
well that's because for the bows
it really doesn't matter how many times
you die as long as you die
a good death dying usually means you're
doing something aggressive right it's
very very very uncommon that you will
see me die
under my own turret
playing defensive so you play aggressive
right and what happens is people pick up
on all the times that i die when i play
aggressive and you know oh it's another
good death you know he died
but people have a hard time picking up
whenever the aggressive play works out
for example i think that's a big thing
that maybe i will die five out of six
times but then that one time that i kill
him is a game changer and i proceed to
win the game because of that play i
don't know how to explain i guess it's
just i play way more aggressive um it
works out
[Music]
yes it didn't flash
yes
nice good death good
death in essence the boss is essentially
the living embodiment of lose lane
win game
like even he's surprised when he
finishes a match with a positive kda
i've never been in this position where i
win lane
what the [ __ ] what am i supposed to do
now what do you do when you win lane
don't think you do this
the thing is not everyone has a good
sense of humor about how the bousse
approaches league even though his fan
base has grown considerably over the
years so too has his number of critics
many of whom claim that he's a glorified
griefer worthy of being permabanned and
unfortunately for the baus the yokes
temporarily came to an abrupt halt in
january of 2021 when he was slapped with
a ban from riot for intentionally
feeding although the ban was lifted and
flagged as a mistake by riot's game
director mark yetter the baus believes
the motivations were a little more
sinister basically
in high heels
there are a lot of people that are not
very liked i think i'm one of them there
are many people that dislike me straight
up because of my place i like it's a
small community high elo we we play with
each other every day the same people
over and over again so you know i
wouldn't be surprised if there are
people that report me every single game
even if i play well
just because they dislike me but
whichever side of the baus debate you
fall on there's no denying that he has
made a sizable impact on the league
community not just for his in-game
antics but for his unique spin on common
phrases like we're chillin and
easy gg we shielding guys we're
shielding
oh
yes
dude we shielding man like i'm doing
i might be the biggest smurf on this
[ __ ] planet dude holy [ __ ] we're
[ __ ]
why oh my god
we're the guys we shielding end the game
and the game
let's go
[Music]
get out of here this game of my life
well well well what a way to wrap up the
day easy man
but without question the baus's most
famous quip
has to be
solo bolo
[Music]
i really want to stack him you killed
him what
what are you doing to them
you're not meant to kill them you're not
meant to kill them
i meant to kill you if anything at all
i'm the solo master and then finally
solo bolo i think one of the most famous
of your uh terms so is any solo kill a
solo bolo solo
yeah
no there's rules of course to solve
lobolo
first of all no ally assistance it's you
and you alone
no teammate nearby
second of all
if you're a if you're a ribbon you're a
camille and you kill a yumi
that's just a kill you know that's not
really a solo boat there has to be some
kind of fight solo bolo became bigger
than the baus ever could have imagined
especially when he famously crossed
paths with legendary korean top laner
khan in solo queue
huge let's go boys that's huge
he did not just say that man
no he did not just say that dude and it
reached an even higher level of
popularity when chinese casters actually
dropped it during a game at msi
and soon enough his name was on the tip
of everyone's tongues
oh my god
[Music]
that is the boss i was waiting for that
he's so nutty i didn't even know this
was possible before i watched this play
a month ago this this play like actually
yeah
so that's how he wins games guys
oh bro i was watching uh
the boss the bus the bus the trash
played cho'gath earlier
while i was
waiting in my meeting
[Music]
that's some eu entertainment right there
i swear to god that is horrible
the bowser's surging popularity even
landed him a guest analyst role during
the lec summer split and despite some of
the criticism that drew he made the most
of his chance to shine in the spotlight
for tldr for people who don't know you
can you describe yourself in like three
words
i'm just a streamer a very bad at games
and that's what i'm known for okay
at the end of the day whether you're a
fan of his or not the baus has found a
way to conquer league of legends with
one of the most unique playstyles the
game has ever seen you may not like it
but maybe
this is what peak league of legends
looks like shakeo one trick bro he knows
how to get over the walls
oh he doesn't even need to see him he
doesn't need to see him he's got the
glasses on he's playing blindfolded he's
throwing the blind cues oh he's the boss
for a reason sure he dies shockingly
often but more often than not he gets
that enemy nexus down first using every
dirty scion trick in the book
oh [ __ ]
that's cold dude
that was
that was close
and most importantly he does it his way
you can try to be the greatest high
death turret smashing undead pest that
league of legends has ever seen
but you'll never be the boss
oh the whole gang
okay we're driving
okay hello what up [ __ ]
they think they're ganking on the bot
lane i go video
let's go dude
pilot i used to play for cloud9 and he
was the position for support who would
roam around and just feed he would sack
his life to gain intel and he would
relay all this information to his team
and then every once in a while they'd
find him i remember it distinctly of
casters being like tactical feeding ah
and they're laughing like it's tactical
it's good it's good like it's right
that's what it came to mind for me was
pile i die with his tactical feeding